First let's take a look
at the security of iOS.
The iOS security architecture
combines both software and
hardware features to provide security to
an iOS device such as an iPhone or iPad.
It has built in crypto capabilities
to support data protection,
such as confidentiality and integrity.
For example,
notice that the crypto engine and
the crypto keys are embedded
in the hardware.
And of course, beta protection is
applied to not just the system files but
also application data.
The security architecture also provides
various strong isolation mechanisms, for
example, it uses App Sandbox
to protect app security.
This enables the apps to run securely.
For example, apps cannot
interfere with each other and
also this ensure
the integrity of the system.
That is, even if an app is compromised,
it's damage to the system
is very limited.